so my name is john fultz for those who
don't know me
uh i'm with the user interface group
user interface group does uh
can anybody hear me fine yeah so the
user interface group
works on the mathematica front end
we work on a bunch of uh uh a bunch of
mobile apps
some of which we shipped out the doors
some of which are still under
development
and the underdevelopment ones you're
going to hear
about in some other talks
and uh gosh it seems like
lately it seems like there's nothing i
don't have my fingers in but
i'm going to focus this talk just on the
mathematica
desktop front end or wolf from desktop
if that's your flavor
if you've attended talks that i've given
in the past
a lot of times i'm showing
shiny new demos of things that you can't
use
because we haven't shipped them yet uh i
decided to mix it up a bit
and show you some shiny demos of things
that you can
use today uh
yes it's because i'm kind of out of
shiny demos of
of stuff that doesn't work but uh uh but
i still have a few ideas of things that
we might want to discuss at the end
okay so let's get started
well of course the big victory lap for
for our group is
multiple undo um
thank you cheap applause i love it well
it wasn't that cheap it was it was a lot
of effort but
uh but i'll i'll take it um the uh
so this was this was a hard problem for
us to solve and i won't
belabor you with with all of the details
but there are a few things that kind of
that kind of affects how we implemented
it
and how you end up using it in the
product
and so i did want to talk a little bit
about those
um so stephen alluded to this a little
bit
yesterday in his talk one of the things
that's
that's an interesting challenge is uh
is that we have really two notions
of uh of history um that there is uh
um uh there is the kernel
which is a strictly chronological
history
uh it's you know every time you press
shift enter something new happens
and it kind of doesn't matter where on
the screen you do that and it might
replace some existing stuff
um the front end is the more traditional
undo problem of you know i type
someplace at some point in time and then
i want to be able to undo that
the but one of the things that
that we realized early on um
actually not quite at the beginning but
but
when we started to have an undo feature
that that came up and was starting to
work was that
it was very confusing if we were to
uh uh if we were to
undo evaluations when i say undo
evaluations we're not literally undoing
kernel state but we're undoing the
effects
in your notebook and it was
very easy to kind of lose track of
what's going on
and and you know in your head you're
trying to think i want to undo back to a
particular point but you couldn't figure
out if you were at that point or not
and one of the big indicators of that um
was uh or one of the big things that you
might want to achieve is you might want
to undo to a point where
for a given input and output that the
inputs and outputs
correspond to one another and so
we came up with a fairly interesting
solution to that
and i have to say this is something that
i'm almost as proud of as multiple undo
itself
um it's a
something that if you've been using
version 10 you probably have
seen uh so if i start typing here
if i start to add
wow um tell you what let me let me come
out of slideshow mode
at this may be turned off for slideshow
mode here
there we go okay yeah
so if um
i should have checked that beforehand so
if i if i start typing here
it dims down the output and what does
that mean um
uh that means that the input and the
output are no longer in sync
so easy enough and that means that when
you're when i'm undoing if i
undo my keystrokes i can kind of figure
out now uh
you know get a really easy visual cue
of uh of whether
whether this is the point maybe where i
should stop pressing command z
or control z or not but the interesting
thing is
this is actually kind of useful in a
number of
other ways and one of the things that i
always want to do is you know i go and i
like reformat my code or something like
that i insert some new lines
uh and previously whenever i've done
that uh
you know it always takes away my my uh
my cell labels here and i want and i
want to know
uh did i make any changes that actually
affect the output and it's actually
telling me this here so
uh so it's telling me that this new line
isn't going to affect the output in any
way and if i type a comment
it's going to gray down and then when i
close the comment
once again it knows this doesn't affect
the output in any way so it restores my
color
so now
you know to to be clear it's it's not
it's not actually communicating with the
kernel this is about uh
whether or not uh changes uh whether or
not the front end's actually sending
something different to the kernel so if
i were to retype
this uh if i retype that typeset pi
there
as the symbol pi uh that is going to
stay
gray because we're actually sending
different stuff to the kernel so
um but uh useful feature
let me drop back in here so
um in fact uh you know kind of uh you
know
subtle visual indicators to make
multiple undo a lot easier to use but it
turns out to be useful otherwise
now one of the other
challenges is that sometimes you have
stuff that's going on simultaneously
inside inside the front end
and it might not be in terms of the time
that it pops into the notebook
that might not define the sequence in
which you actually want to undo
operations
what does that mean so let me just show
a quick example here
i have a slow computation which is going
to be spitting out
multiple cells here and so
i'm going to start that running and i'm
going to
make another cell here
and keep typing while this evaluation is
running
and we'll go ahead and let that finish
here
so if we were looking strictly at
chronology
then what you would expect to happen is
uh is a bunch of bouncing around when i
do multiple undo and uh
that's not that's not so pleasant and
that's not what we do
so what we do you see it undoes
my typing and then
it undoes the evaluation in one fell
swoop
i mean you know do you do you really
want to undo individual cells of the
evaluation
no so it just undoes it one in one fell
swoop and we can
put it all back in there as well
so this is um this is another one of
those things where the challenge of the
front end
uh uh you know the challenge of working
in mathematica
you know makes multiple undo uh not so
straightforward
and as you can imagine this might
actually lead to inconsistencies where
uh where undo might potentially get
confused
uh if you know they're because we're
attempting to
do things in a sensible order undo you
know it might
turn into a pathological problem for
undo
but but the way that we implemented undo
it's it has a bunch of
internal consistency checks it's
actually it's actually hashing bits of
the notebook
at the various undo stages so that
if undo is about to do something that
corrupts your notebook
it stops it knows that it's about to do
something dangerous
it stops it backs out and uh uh
so you may find yourself sometimes uh
you know pressing
undo and then you know it'll start
beeping on you and it won't undo anymore
and you'll be like what happened to my
undo stack is because undo knows that
if it were to keep going it might damage
your notebook and it's not going to do
that
so we've had enough experience damaging
notebooks in the past didn't want to
introduce new causes
so normally mouse click interfaces don't
undo
what am i what do i mean by mouse click
interfaces i mean like sliders check
boxes pop-up menus that sort of thing
and if you type inside an input field
that's going to undo of course
but but if i
if i move my slider around and then i
press
command z on my macintosh once um
that didn't register and undo it just
undoes the evaluation that created that
in the first place
so i think that's pretty sensible what
most people expect but one of the things
that we discovered
is that sometimes sometimes these
user interfaces are not uh
are not what you expect i mean they may
they may not feel like using a user
interface they may feel like editing
in some way and the big thing where this
came up for us was the control equal
interface
uh we we eat our own dog food and
we built the control equal interface out
of out of first class
mathematic you know mathematical user
interface controls uh
and so the uh uh we needed
some way to be able to tie into the undo
system
and so we added this option called undo
track variables
i mean you know i mentioned this this is
sort of a minor thing for a keynote
level presentation but
if you need it you'll be glad i
mentioned it um
and so the uh so here
you know once again same thing that i
did before but now i
undo undo undo
so now that slider is part of the undo
stack
so like i said a minor thing but if you
need it
you'll be glad that you came to this
talk
so uh another
thing that i'm really happy with uh and
i think it says something about
how the how the desktop uh front end
continues to progress
is some of the very sophisticated
systems which are built
in uh in the front end and
so in version 10 the stuff that you're
seeing
and some of this stuff has already been
demoed a bit and there's going to be
some more talks on some of it as well
so testing notebooks this is a system
that very heavily relies on the front
end and i'm not going to steal from
from raj's talk raj is giving a talk on
friday
but i will just point out this is uh
this is the unit testing uh
functionality which we included
as uh a part of version 10
where you can where you can type in your
unit test
and and get your green bar there
and stephen demo this and raj will do
much more i'm
but uh but that's a system that very
heavily relies
on the front end uh the uh
the wolfram programming lab which steven
demoed and came up
in a talk that conrad gave yesterday as
well
and possibly some others is
is another system that's built in the
desktop front end and
you know these things are built using
public interfaces and using things
that that anyone here could write with
enough study of the documentation
the template notebooks i want to discuss
a little bit because i was going through
the
i was going through the schedule and i
noticed i don't think there's talk on
this
so i'm not going to go too deep into it
but
i did have some examples that i had
written
for another talk and so let me just uh
let me just talk about
uh talk about that briefly so what is a
template notebook i mean this is this is
report generation
uh this is the idea that uh you want to
be able to
programmatically uh plug in
things into notebooks
and you know it gets more sophisticated
that than that as well you might be able
to
want to be able to run code
that uh um you know run code
contextually
inside a pl uh a bit of the notebook you
might want to
have something that uh that loops within
the notebook and creates
a series of content cells uh
and so um let me
open up this example here example two
why is it example two
because i forgot to change the two for a
one when i copy this from another talk
not because i missed something here okay
so this is an example template notebook
and
um i mean you can get a fresh one once
again
file new template notebook um
the uh but this is one that i built and
so let me just discuss
a little bit of what we've done here so
first of all it's a real notebook
you're just uh you're just doing
anything in the notebook that you want
to
i have right here i have
a section cell i have a text cell down
here
now they happen to have some
programmatic content in them and so in
this case
this is some programmatic content here
this uh
this guy here which basically is going
to evaluate
in place date string and
the result will come back it'll be
plugged right in there
uh so that's generic mathematical code
in this case this is going to evaluate
something which is going to grab data
from the
from the data that i'm inserting into
the template if we uh
if we look at uh
look at the code that i'm saying up here
so i have an association that has these
two things currency list
and and name so these are keys which are
going to be plugged in
to uh to this particular template here
so in this case this is just taking the
key
uh or taking the value for the key name
it's just going to plug it in right
there
uh and this is just taking the value for
the key currency list is plugging in
right there
uh and okay well this is kind of ugly
you know am i really going to have an
input cell coming out
no because uh because one of the things
i can do with input cells is i can
control their behavior
so uh so this uh this menu right here
allows me to
uh with particular input cell attach a
behavior to it
and the behavior that i've attached to
to both of the input cells that you're
seeing here actually is evaluate and
delete
and so in this case this is going to
evaluate i've put a semicolon in
on the end so it's not going to turn
into an output
this one is going to evaluate and delete
as well and most of these things have
semicolons except for the last one so
this is actually going to produce a
panel in the outputs
okay and so let's uh
uh let's actually then switch back
and run our templates so here's the data
that i'm going to stick in
and then we'll go ahead and run it and
this is going to take just a little bit
to run because it's going out on the
internet i'm actually
fetching today's currency exchange rates
so
this this document is generated
just for you
and so here we go now i actually define
things in a loop so
i have multiple slides here i have i
have the euro exchange rates i have the
dollar exchange rates
and the yen and the pound sterling
and the ruble there we go so
so this was uh now this is kind of
interesting it's
sitting here in a slideshow how did i do
this
well like i said we're just dealing with
regular notebooks
and if we go back into the regular
notebook
and take a look and we'll see that uh
that this this notebook too is just
a slideshow and it's a little hidden
because of the styles that are used here
uh but uh but you can see right there at
the bottom it's telling us slide zero of
one
and so the way that i set this up was i
just had
had a slide break inside the repeating
block uh
and so that's how i generated my uh
my automatic slideshow but the point
being
um you know there's nothing magic about
slideshows
any feature of notebooks that you want
to use for template notebooks
they're there because template notebooks
in the end are just notebooks
ian hodgnicki talked a little bit about
this at uh want to talk to yesterday i'm
not going to go into the level of detail
that he did but i want to
i want to point out that one of the
major features
of version 10 is that we're now
integrated
the front end is now integrated into the
cloud file system so
anything that you do uh in the cloud
platform it's available for you right
there in the desktop
and opening and saving these files are
first class operations
we do have to have a separate menu item
simply because you need to know whether
you're targeting the
cloud or the desktop but
but i am already logged in here if i
hadn't been logged in it would have
asked me to log in
and that is a little bit slower than
we'd like for it to be we're
still working on the performance there
but uh but it's pretty solid stuff i can
i can navigate the file hierarchy
however i want to i can open up things
right off the uh
right off the cloud file system so
that's going to open up
i can come in here and i can
make my changes
and now because we totally understand
that we're dealing
with the cloud file system if i if i
just do command s
it's going to go right back and
you'll see while the full screen stuff
kind of flipped around on me but uh
but you'll see that we have the monitor
that shows us that we just push stuff
back to the server
so uh so first class operations
and and we and we do this queuing of
files being pushed up to the server
intelligently
which is to say that uh if you try to
quit mathematica before you've pushed up
you know we'll we'll we'll stop you and
let you know we're still doing work if
uh
if you cue up the same file several
times
uh we'll just take the last instance of
the thing in that queue
so it's you know intelligent cueing of
files going to the server
and but
but otherwise when you do save you don't
have to wait for the save operation to
happen you can
keep on going and that's okay
so we did some more improvements to code
assist code assist is our
internal name for a collection of
functionality which uh
a lot of which deals with automatic
completions of some sort but things
which
somehow help you to be able to write
code
faster more accurately better so
uh so and if you've been using version
10 you'll have seen
some of these you you know you may or
may not have have appreciated
some of the specifics of how these
things work previous versions we've been
able to
do completion on any individual symbol
that's fine but we can do better than
that
so now we understand lots of functions
that don't take symbols
that take strings of various sorts and
so we do
you know if i want to save as a
gif or something like that i apologize
it's probably coming out a little small
on the screen there i didn't set up the
magnification for this but uh
but now i can just uh you know tab my
way through that
and i get the choice that i want um
and not only that um actually let's uh
let's uh let's do exports instead of
export string
and now i can do
now i've got completion uh that's
actually coming from my file system
so uh and that's uh
that is sensitive to functions that
actually care about
files uh so you know it's a lot of
curation of data on our part to
kind of figure out uh which functions
should have what types of completions we
did all that work uh
so color function completion this is a
nice one
if i want to do if i want to do color
data now i can i can complete the color
data that's fine but there's a secondary
choice this choose color scheme and now
i actually have access to uh
this is you may recognize this uh
because we have a palette that looks a
lot like this and we just embedded the
palette right there in the notebook
um oops um just click there
so so if i want to choose
pastel and it doesn't work i've got a
couple
things when i go into slideshow mode not
work the way i
uh anticipate let me just
once again come out of slideshow mode
here so i can more effectively
demonstrate some of this stuff
um
yeah okay
interesting
well it wouldn't be fun if this sort of
thing didn't happen from time to time
right
um that's okay uh
it worked in this very version in this
very instance of mathematica last night
so
okay moving on um the and it works on
your system
that's a guarantee from me it works on
your system
okay um
option right hand side completion uh
i like this one a lot this is another
one where we did
we did a lot of curation
so i'm just completing to uh plot
legends
but i can't remember i can't remember
what right hand size plot legends takes
uh well look at that expressions that
looks like something that i might be
interested in
um and uh let's do uh
let's uh set up our plot theme as well
fine uh and in this case
not only do i have a list of plot themes
but i can actually see what they look
like
and so well that's the
scientific one here looks sort of
interesting
and so now we can
we can do that and it's a lot less
thinking a lot less referencing the
documentation
it's sometimes it's like we're reading
your mind
gosh you're about four slides ahead of
me
um the brief answer is so the question
was
can you as a developer access some of
this stuff um
and uh for the straightforward
completions and function templates the
answer is yes you can plug your stuff
into there in terms of function
templates we just look at standardized
usage usage messages
but in terms of the curated stuff
not yet on our agenda we know you want
it
okay uh and the uh the other thing
that i want to point out let me give
myself a
little room here below so you guys can
see this
is that these uh these completions are
contact sensitive so here i have
a completion for method
and this is the method to indie solve
and it's giving me things like
runge-kutta and bdf
and close close and now i'm going to set
a method for my button
and now it's giving me options like cued
and preemptive
so uh so
it's uh uh in some cases you know
options look the same across many many
functions but in some cases they don't
we're aware of that
so one thing that's new to version 10 we
had a
we had uh an editor uh for
2d images uh which we made a few
improvements to but
kind of not enough to make a really
shiny demo here but uh
but we added a a a similar sort of uh
editor for 3d images uh
and once again this one i caught before
the talk that i'm going to have to
take myself out of slideshow mode again
here so we'll go ahead and do that
and
okay so 3d images aren't new
you've seen them before if you've been
here at least
but now if you click on one
you get a little bar at the bottom
with some tools and there's some
interesting stuff going on here
we have a color function editor
which allows us to take a look at
uh i mean we have our default color
function but we can
we can choose any custom color function
we want
uh if well that was terrible
um uh let's
let's try uh okay
well that's for a certain kind of person
that's probably okay
but but then we can also
actually edit these things by hand if we
want to try to
filter out some of the noise and
highlight certain kinds of data
and we can even add
uh add extra sliders so that we can have
kind of more control over that
and we apply that and we go
go up here we also have
clip planes
and this is sorry this is a little
awkward simply because of the size of my
screen here
but uh so here i i have a clip plane
which is uh
defined by this interval slider i mean
right now
it's the it's just showing the entire
oops
let me make this window a bit bigger
okay so right now it's uh defined as
ah we have a resolution here let me make
the image smaller
okay
okay so now i can
i can just look at a slice of this
i can move that slice through
and i can do it in in different planes
as well
once again make the slice however thick
or thin as i want and then move it
through
so and uh
and still be able to rotate it around do
all the other things that we like
and of course you know we i mean we can
set up multiple clipping
planes if we want i won't bore you with
that but it's
really you know we're taking the ability
to visualize the 3d image data
and we're trying to make it very very
simple
okay
so this is one of those things that
might pass unnoticed by you because
it's not really i mean it's a feature
that we had before
pdf export but for people who've tried
to rely on pdf export you know that
it's been kind of problematic for a
little while and it's been problematic
because of
because
there are some things that pdf just is
not very good at
that we do a lot of i mean pdf isn't
really very good at dealing with
gradients or transparency uh
or uh or high polygon counts um
and uh so you know we do this balance
between
uh between trying to
send things to bitmap when you know send
things to pdf as bitmap when we have to
when pdf just can't figure it out
or trying to do uh a
high quality sort of uh
sort of export but uh but frankly what
we did in version nine
you know have been in doing in verse 8
and version nine uh you know there are a
lot of people who are hoping we could do
better
uh and this version we have uh and so
you can just ignore the code here just
the the point being that uh
uh i just made a little function which
indicates some sizes because the size of
pdf is actually one of the interesting
changes
from version 9 to version 10.
and that is that is just flipping out
because
it's i set something up here to uh
to shell out to version nine and
run this same code export string
and and grab the size so in version nine
if we if we just do
an exports of the expression a plus b
uh it's uh 31 kilobytes or so
and in version 10 if we do the same
thing as eight kilobytes
um and so what we did is we actually
threw away everything we were doing
about pdf export before
it was it was just uh um
there wasn't enough to be rescued there
and we started over from scratch and one
of the things that we support
is we now support subsetting of fonts
this is actually one of the reasons why
there's a big
difference in this particular example is
because uh
because in version nine we're including
uh
the math fonts which are necessary for
that plus sign there
and more of that more of this size is
font than image
and in version 10 we only include
the portions of the font that are
actually required to generate the image
so
trying to get pdf size down uh and just
to
show you an example you know if we're
comparing the string
alpha beta versus alpha the difference
in version nine is very small because it
already included the entire font in
there
and the difference in version 10 is a
little bit more modest because it's now
including the spline definition for beta
so it's you only pay the incremental
cost that you actually need
um the in general in terms of size
uh it is very often going to be a win in
version 10 over version 9 and some of
the sizes
you know in version 10 i mean i'm
showing simple examples here but some of
the sizes really got
unmanageably large uh so this was
you know one of the nice things when i
uh when i implemented multiple undo i
i went through my bug list and i went
through every undo bug that i had and
there were probably about
40 of them and i think i closed 38 of
them
and pdf same thing except there were
more bug reports than that and we closed
a whole bunch of them for version 10.
um the
and one of the really ornery things was
dealing with 3d graphics
so uh so in version nine
i mean it's just trying to do something
which is uh internally which is not very
reasonable for 3d graphics and won't go
into the details
uh and this unfortunately uh this is the
one place where i'm going to break my
rule a bit and say
this isn't the version that you have but
this is the version that you will have
very soon
uh this is i'm i'm running the candidate
for
uh for 10.02 which will be pushing out
the door
very very shortly and so you'll you'll
see this uh right now there's still a
bit of a problem with 3d graphics but
you'll see this
coming soon and what it's doing for 3d
graphics really because 3d graphics
that's just the worst case scenario for
uh for pdf where if we try to do it
uh you know faithfully as a vector
representation
this is what you're going to get and on
top of that the quality is going to
suffer as well
and some you know you'll end up with
holes in your polygons
still and such it's just a limitation
of a format which was created
in the early 90s and really hasn't seen
much of an update since then uh so
what we're doing actually by default is
we're throwing in 300 dpi
images into here which is generally
going to be enough but that's adjustable
if you need it
so so not a particularly shiny thing
it's an old feature but now
one that i think will work much better
for you
okay so uh some other features not to
miss i'm not going to spend
too much time on any one of these i
don't have a demo for any of them but i
just want to
uh you know these are things which you
might easily not be aware of
although if you're running uh if you're
running a
macbook pro with retina display you
probably are aware that we are now
finally supporting retina displays
but if you've been waiting on buying one
of the macbook pros because of that
now you can stop waiting now
on the uh on the windows side
we do unfortunately uh we don't support
dpi scaling yet on the windows side that
does affect some new
windows laptops one of those windows
laptops
that it affects is mine so we'll get
this working
uh but uh sorry we're not there yet in
shipping versions
um we also have the proper full screen
support
uh which was oh i think it was
introduced maybe in leopard or something
like that
at the full screening of apps and uh
took us a while to get on board with
that but you see me using it during this
talk
uh under windows we ditched the floating
menu bar
which was a great idea in 1996 uh
and then started to look like less of a
great idea as the years went on
um so uh we put out a new uh
uh a new version uh
of the front end uh well the front end
of the kernel will from desktop which
has this new licensing option
which some of you may not appreciate um
uh
you know if you're happy with the
mathematical licensing option that's
fine
uh so wolfram desktop is part of it
comes with a subscription plan
the downside is you're paying money
every month but the upside is
uh all you have to do is log in and it
will work you can log in from as many
computers as you want to
so uh so if you're you know a highly
portable person going from computer to
computer that's now an option for you
and uh and at the right subscription
level that is
uh it is it has all the features
every bit as powerful as what you see in
mathematica
so uh we also did some
updating of fonts uh including unifying
our numbered fonts
uh not something you care about but
something that caused me a great deal of
pain for
two or three months um the uh and and
one of the
uh one of the things that we also did is
we added a sans serif uh
font for uh for mathematical stuff
so uh 3d inset
um texture maps on field curves
u2 lou will be giving a talk later i
think it's later today
where he's going to be talking about
some of this stuff so if you're
interested in that
and and i talked a little bit about
some improvements that we made to the 2d
image editor uh
and then it kind of once again kind of a
small thing but if you've ever used file
name setter you've probably run into
this limitation and
we haven't had a very good story for it
and now um
now file names that are uh pretty much
all the issues that you probably ever
ran into before
are now gone
so i'm finished talking about the things
that
uh that we shipped as part of version 10
but here i want to talk about stuff
even though i don't have shiny demos for
this well in some cases i do actually
have working code but
uh but i don't have shiny demos but the
reason i want to talk about this is
because this is the conversation
that i want to have with you um it's a
little bit inconvenient for you to come
up to my office
uh two or three weeks from now uh you're
here i'm here
uh and so if you want to talk about
stuff that really matters to you
uh i'll just mention a few things that
really matter to me but
i'd like to hear your ideas too um and
so these are some things that are on my
radar and we actually have
uh you know early technology or
uh or or designs worked out for a number
of these things
um so integration with git if you don't
know what git is
sorry but you know it's the uh it's the
technology behind github which you
probably
have heard of and that
that is something that i have some real
technology on my system for
improvements in unit testing uh raj is
giving the talk on friday and unit
testing
we've been helping them to implement
some of that stuff but i've taken a much
bigger interest in this and so i have
some real ideas going forward here
code assistance is something that we are
always working on
and trying to trying to uh read your
minds even better
uh issues uh with how we deploy i mean
there's been
for a while there's been uh some
questions about the
you know the cdf deployment story and
things are changing right now because
the web browser plug-in
let's face it uh the future of the web
browser plug-in does not look good
um uh we're all you know we're seeing
signals from pretty much
all of the browser folks that uh that
these sorts of plugins
the end is on the horizon we see it
coming so
uh we put a lot of effort into it but
that's okay
we have some other really strong ideas
for deployment some of them we're
already seeing today
with the cloud platform but we have some
more ideas coming as well
and i know it's something that a lot of
you care about so
digital signing maybe doesn't sound that
important but digital signing maybe i
should have written
the feature that will make dynamic
warnings go away
uh so that's what digital signing is
so a few other things in terms of some
interface stuff that we're looking at
now this is something that we're
actually shipping in
undocumented experimental form right now
uh spreadsheet
type control for handling tabular data
we have this thing called table view
and we actually snuck in and it works
feel free to play around with it it's
not fin
it's not documented yet though because
it's not finished um
uh ribbons and floating interfaces we've
been building a lot of these ourselves
and we'd like for you to be able to
build them too
uh we have pretty good idea how that's
gonna work and i think we're not very
far actually
from being able to deliver on some of
that technology and
this was i said you're about four slides
ahead
developer control over over the
completions and code assist stuff
and then these are questions that we
hear about
uh when are we going to do coco it's
happening right now
it's we are working on this in fact uh
i don't know where he is but uh if if
yeah yeah i i yes the fella the fella
who's working on this
is apparently not here because he's
working on it right now
uh we're also working on uh updating the
technology under the linux version which
uh runs uh qt4 with a little bit of qt3
behind it we're upgrading that as well
and uh we're and we're working on
upgrading the drawing support for uh for
the windows version
which uh using a technology called
direct write is basically
you know microsoft microsoft is very
good about supporting the legacy
technologies but still
they said we have a new technology and
oh by the way uh we have all these new
features which are only available in new
technologies so
uh so we're looking at acceleration for
2d drawing and some
some much better font rendering it
really makes a huge difference and so
that is something that uh if you're
wondering why that's not done yet it's
because
ian came to the talk
and then your ideas i'm i'm serious
about this you know
i i go on to the community and to stack
exchange and i want to hear what you
guys are talking about and i'm here
right now come to talk to me
and so i'll just plug a few other talks
jason harris is doing
uh a workshop on type setting jason's
right there uh
right after this talk is over uh in the
other room uh
i mentioned that u2 is going to be
giving a talk on graphics
chris carlson is giving a talk on
integration with rhino this is kind of a
design-oriented talk
uh and that actually i think i'll be
attending that myself i'm
interested to see what he's doing uh the
cdf player for ios
robert a schofield is going to be
talking about that later to today and
then we have talks tomorrow
also coming out of stuff my group is
doing with
cdf deployment in general by andre and
the wolfram calculator
that jeremiah cunningham is going to be
giving